good morning job paternity leave break
what am I doing here I pre-recorded this
video because I have some things to tell
you about vidcon's vidcon's three of
them take my favorite thing about being
a YouTube creators that lets have you on
a stage unless we talk to you in real
life VidCon is one of the only times of
year you get to get together and see
each other I don't want a TV show I want
to be a pioneer of something brand-new
we should only be sharing our ideas in
the environment that enables us to do
that the best let go of the ego behind
it instead I'm focused on what matters
which is reaching the audience and
nothing enables that like like the
Internet
[Music]
- no matter what
and level two
we come together at VidCon to immerse
ourselves in the world of online video
to connect with our friends and our
communities to capture and reflect the
state of this ever-changing and thriving
culture and simply to celebrate we are
pleased to announce the VidCon u.s. will
return to the Anaheim Convention Center
for another exceptional weekend June
21st to 24th and for the first time ever
VidCon is going global
VidCon Europe will kick-off April 8th
and 9th in Amsterdam with VidCon
Australia following on September 9th and
10th in Melbourne these are two cities
that foster innovation and collaboration
they're cosmopolitan friendly and lively
cities and we're very excited to see how
VidCon lives and breathes in these new
homes tickets are officially available
now for VidCon u.s. VidCon Europe and
VidCon Australia I hope to see you there
I'm so excited to be going to these
things I've never been to Amsterdam I've
never been to the southern hemisphere no
Australia no City no Melbourne no
anything I will be at all three Anaheim
Amsterdam and Melbourne John you're only
gonna be able to be at Anaheim so I will
just have to be both me and you for
those people there which I think I could
pull off I'm working on your signature
it's not complicated and maybe you could
like you can Skype in for a dear Hank
and John that beef I say without having
asked you about that first we're digging
into the really interesting creator
communities in these places but we will
also be bringing creators from the US
and the UK we're so lucky at VidCon to
be able to represent a diversity of
creators and creations and going
international is a humongous step in
that direction for us I'm really excited
about it I think it's gonna be a ton of
fun I apologize to you for coming back
from Leave temporarily just to let most
of you know about events that you're not
going to be able to be at I feel very
bad for all the people who live far away
from these events but now there are
fewer of you for everybody who can come
I'm so excited to see you in Anaheim
Melbourne and Amsterdam
John thank you so much for taking care
of this place and for all of our guest
hosts for taking care of this space
while I've been gone
I don't know how it's done because as I
said I pre-recorded this because I am on
leave
thanks for not burning the channel down
I assume and I'll see you on Tuesday